[Music]
the world has changed a lot in the past
1000 years
but for most of that time one thing
remained the same
the amount of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
but in the late 18th century this
happened
and the levels began to climb
and then in the 20th century it goes to
the look it goes to levels that it's not
been seen at in nature for millions of
years the increase in atmospheric carbon
is the biggest contributor to climate
change the key to reversing the damage
restoring earth's delicately balanced
carbon cycle
the way carbon moves around the earth is
known as the carbon cycle
it consists of sources which emit carbon
into the atmosphere
and sinks which take carbon out of it
the biological side of the carbon cycle
is pretty near perfect it works like
this
respiration for example when animals
breathe
emits carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
then plants bacteria and algae
take co2 out of the atmosphere during
photosynthesis
the process they use to generate
chemical energy
oceans are both sources and sinks
carbon dioxide is endlessly being
absorbed into the oceans
and released from the oceans at almost
exactly the same rate
the system naturally balances itself out
if there's more carbon dioxide being
drawn down
into the biosphere then more carbon
dioxide will be put
back into the atmosphere if the
atmospheric level of complexity goes up
the levels by which it's absorbed by the
oceans and the plants will go up too
similar scientists call it dynamic
equilibrium
but a few hundred years ago this dynamic
equilibrium was knocked out of kilter
when organisms die some of the carbon
stored inside them
gets buried underground stopping it from
going back into the atmosphere
for hundreds of millions of years this
fossil carbon was left mostly
undisturbed
until humans started to dig it up and
burn it as fuel
the way humans have changed the carbon
cycle is one of the reasons some
scientists say the earth has entered the
anthropocene
the geological age when human activity
is the dominant influence on the
environment
today fossil fuels add an extra 9.5
billion tonnes of carbon into the
atmosphere
think about all the petrol that's poured
into all the cars in all the cities in
the world
think about all the coal that's going
into all the power plants in all the
countries in the world
think about all the gas that's being
burnt on all the burners of the
stoves of the whole world that's what
gives you
9.5 billion tons roughly half of this
extra carbon from fossil fuels
is absorbed by the earth's sinks but the
rest that makes it to the atmosphere
traps heat
warming the planet this has had a
devastating effect on the world's
climate
it also changes how well carbon sinks
function
this is where things get complicated and
scary as
temperature changes the environment
changes and that may not be good for the
sink
in the ocean cooler water absorbs more
carbon dioxide so as the oceans warm
up their ability to absorb carbon
dioxide goes down
plants photosynthesize more if there's
more carbon dioxide which you would
think is good
but plants synthesize less if they're
dead and if the climate changes so that
a large
number of plants die the photosynthesis
of the planet will go down
human action took a sledgehammer to the
earth's delicately balanced carbon cycle
the damage is not irrevocable but only
humans can fix it
the first thing to do if you want to get
the carbon cycle back into a stable
balance
is to stop pushing it that means
reducing human emissions from fossil
fuels
as quickly as you can
the growing green movement proves there
is an appetite for that
but emissions aren't being cut as
severely as they need to be
at very best you could say that the rate
at which carbon emissions from fossil
fuels
has grown has maybe slowed a little bit
the international politics of climate
change
makes cutting carbon emissions
particularly difficult
you can find out why by clicking on the
link above
but even if humans stopped using fossil
fuels and carbon emissions was zero
the amount of carbon in the atmosphere
would not return to pre-industrial
levels
it would just stop growing to bring
atmospheric carbon levels
down humans need to build systems that
either create a new sink
or amplify the actions of an old sink
these are called negative emission
schemes
in terms of amplifying an old sink you
might restore a forest that have been
degraded
you might change the way that you run
pasture land so that the soil stores
more carbon
in terms of a new thing you might
actively
suck carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere
and pump it back down into into geology
this is known as direct air capture
mechanical systems suck carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere
the carbon is then either stored
underground or reused
for example to make fuel or to make new
rock
[Music]
negative emission schemes work well to
offset some of the carbon humans emit
but when it comes to rebalancing the
carbon cycle they're not a perfect
solution
if you concentrate on negative emissions
then you're kind of giving yourself a
license to go on polluting and that's
something that is a very dangerous trend
second problem with negative emissions
they are relatively
inefficient pulling tens hundreds of
billions of tons of carbon out of the
atmosphere
through industrial means is a massive
undertaking
the negative emission schemes that are
being developed today work on a very
small scale
in order for them to actually have a
positive lasting impact
the world's economic structure would
need to change drastically
it's like running the whole fossil fuel
industry in reverse and then some
that's why relying on them when we have
nothing
like this of like infrastructure or
economic incentives or history to
know that we're going to do them it's
such a dangerous idea
at some point humans will stop burning
fossil fuels
either by choice or by force
by the time that happens the world will
look very different to what it does
now it took just a few hundred years to
destroy the dynamic equilibrium of the
carbon cycle but it'll take many
hundreds more
to restore it i'm oliver morton i'm the
briefings editor of the economist
we've written a series of climate briefs
to cover
the basics and a bit more than the
basics on all sorts of aspects of the
climate crisis that's facing the earth
you can read them all at the link
opposite thank you for watching